because she's got such great taste I'd
want to see that oh oh sorry no
it did come up is that there's a
sorry is this right
if she's dating Scoggin
oh sorry it's a fun one you
you mother
[Music]
thank you
you should be there oh wait no you're a
good friend sorry oh wait sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry one second one second
one second
what's the deal with this this guy let
me say that again
um this guy what what's the deal I'm
going shopping my clothes are old
you should call Will
that's what friends do
um or should I say
sir
from 20 years ago so is this oh
can't find your bark
your whole thing was so weird and just
destruction
are you considered a beer which is
jizz no witches unfortunately for you I
am very Charming
why the government doesn't want you to
know that the Earth is flat no uh
patient now
I know that I look relaxed
but I'm not relaxed
I'm very angry
[Music]
[Laughter]